[Music]
so why does this van look so shocked to
see Girl Scout cookies for sale well
look who's holes is a sign if that
really is Jennifer Gardner and we love
al Ghent captioned the shot yet
why yes kind sir we do have been men and
personally I love the Thin Mints - we
just got to put them in the freezer all
right well one thing I never plan to eat
again a habanero pepper you may remember
the Kevin and I took the pepper
challenge to benefit ALS and then we
challenged Garth and his wife Tricia
your way to do it next so they took us
up on it but Kelty night found out who
can really take the heat the family
that's my hot pepper my hot dr. pepper
well it wasn't easy for me that dr.
pepper was hot I'm just telling you
right now it's been a microwave way too
long but the Queen she took that
habanero and she didn't take a bite of
it she she crunched the whole thing it's
hot I want to punch you I'm hashtag wimp
and she's hashtag the man of the house
ya gotta love how Garth bounced down to
his queen is Trisha after 12 years of
marriage these two still know how to US
spice things up in fact after a recent
Facebook live Q&A we are surprised a
Swedish couple with a spontaneous invite
to dinner last night are going on our
honeymoon road trip from Texas to
Florida what shouldn't we miss I'm gonna
get my butt kicked by my wife from this
one why don't you come to our house and
have dinner with me and make sure what
what do you prepare because she's just
such an amazing cook and you are you
gonna do all your favorites that's what
you do yeah case there's any leftovers
you know looking at me you see eating is
what I do best so I'm an expert at it
and I think they're gonna love it
whatever it is
[Applause]
with over 148 million albums sold Garth
was named the first inductee and to pull
stars live Hall of Fame double bonus
that day we also got to celebrate his
56th birthday do you have a birthday
wish anymore you have kids the second
they get college age they just disappear
so Father's Day my birthday and
Christmas are the three days of my life
that I could see all my girls round one
table and thank God for their health
their happiness and just catch up
[Music]